depuis quelques temps on parle beaucoup
des nouveau variant du virus qui cause
la kfw 19 il ya eu celui du royaume uni
et de l'afrique du sud
nos six ans au brésil et plus récemment
en californie il semble être partout
mais les variants c'est quelque chose de
normal dans l'évolution d'un virus on en
a vu des milliers depuis le début de la
pandémie et ils ont pas toujours été une
menace mais ce dont on parle depuis
quelques temps sont différents il se
propage plus rapidement ce qui entraîne
une incertitude dans le comportement du
virus
et ça on en avait vraiment pas besoin
il ya trois mots qui revient dans
l'actualité pour décrire l'évolution
d'un virus mutation va rien et souche
ces trois moulins veulent pas dire la
même chose et pour savoir ce qui ne va
rien il faut être capable de les
distinguer quand un virus vient nous
infectés il prend contrôle de nos
cellules et les forcent à fabriquer des
copies de lui-même
mais le virus et pop parfait il peut
faire des erreurs
en copiant son matériel génétique un peu
comme des fautes de frappe quand on
écrit trouvait à l'ordinateur
ces erreurs sont des mutations la
plupart sont sans importance c'est des
fautes d'orthographe qui vont pas venir
changer le sens une phrase certaines
peuvent même nuire aux virus et peuvent
rendre une phrase il disait blue
incompréhensible mais d'autres peuvent
lui donner des avantages permettre au
virus de se multiplier plus rapidement
ou de se propager plus facilement à
travers la population
ces mutations avantageuses ont tendance
à s'accumuler à travers les générations
un peu comme un livre qui s'améliore
d'une copié à l'autre on dit alors qu'on
fait face à un variant certaines
mutations peuvent aussi changer le virus
profondément faire que le livre du virus
actuel n'est plus reconnaissable quand
on le compare au livre d'origine
on dit qu'on fait alors face à des
souches différentes du virus mais on n'a
pas fait face à cette situation encore
au cours de la pandémie actuelle
présentement il n'ya qu'une souche du
virus sras skov 2 elle est formée de
plusieurs variants et chaque variante
comporte plusieurs mutations
[Musique]
tout dépend de la partie du virus qui
est affecté par les mutations
mais les craintes tournent au taux de 3
points invariants qui serait plus
contagieux invariants qui entraînerait
des symptômes plus graves et invariants
qui serait résistant aux efforts de
vaccination
les vaillants britannique et sud
africains par exemple possèdent des
mutations similaire qui leur permet de
se propager plus facilement mais ne sont
pas plus mortel et jusqu'à maintenant
les résultats préliminaires suggèrent
qu'ils n'ont pas développé de résistance
aux vaccins actuels mais les choses
pourraient changer dans l'avenir avec
l'apparition nouveaux variants tout est
une question de probabilité
c'est un peu comme jouer à un jeu de
hasard ou à une loterie où le plus on a
de participants le plus on a de chance
de tirer le billet gagnant
sauf qu'ici les participants sont les
personnes infectées et bien gagnant
c'est invariant qui va venir nous
compliquer l'existence et avec les
dizaines de millions de personnes qui
sont présentement infectées par le virus
à travers le monde ça fait beaucoup de
participants cette loterie génétique
le seul moyen de s'en sortir c'est de
repérer ces nouveaux variants le plus
rapidement possible et de réduire au
maximum la propagation du virus
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos
questions à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran et nous on va y répondre le plus
rapidement possible